so we are going to continue what was
supposed to be the first talk
and it's lifting ideas from
propositional logic
to face other logic and maria paula
bonacina from
verona will tell us about it please go
forward
thank you very much so i'm going to talk
about
um conflict-driven philosophical
decision procedures
and this is um based on the joint work
with
sarah winkler and joint work with david
placed
now the talk is organized in four parts
i'm going to give some ideas about what
is going on
in automated reasoning beyond the
southern smt
then i'm going to present sggs
which stands for semantically guided
goal sensitive reasoning
and is a method which realizes
conflict-driven reasoning infects or the
logic
and then i'm going to show you recent
investigations on whether in how
sdgs yields decision procedures
for epr and other decidable fragments in
historical
logic please feel free to make questions
at any time
now in automated reasoning
we have different tools based on logic
and usually they are enumerated
so to speak from the decidable towards
the undecidable or
from at the least expressive logic
towards the most expressive
mentioned insert solver smt solver fear
improvers
for extracted logic and proof assistance
for hieroglogic
but the message i would like to give in
this introductory part of the talk
is that the current research trends are
challenging these traditional borders
because much of the research in
automated reasoning today
is about integration and hybridization
of techniques
integration of different methods
integration
of reasoning methods within application
tools
and migration of features that are
considered
typical of one kind of methods to others
for example at the border between
hierarchy and first order logic
we have solvers and provers
embedded inside or invoked as back-end
to proof assistance
and even more advanced than interesting
now we have higher order automated fuel
improvers
superposition which is a solution with
the quality built in
has been generalized to higher order
logic
and so now we have superposition-based
automated fuel improvers
for uh higher quality logic this is
an exciting new development at the
border between
higher order and fixed logic when we
witness
the migration of techniques from
first order to higher order
but also at the border between foxtrot
logic and smt and sat
there are a lot of new things happening
there are approaches for
having quantifiers which is really the
essence of the fixed
reasoning in satisfiability modulo
theories
and we have which is if you wish a
migration of something from
extraordinary logic to smt but we also
have
a migration in the other direction with
the lifting
of a conflict-driven reasoning as in
cbcl
to fix together logic which is the topic
of this talk
now what is the conflict-driven
reasoning in this audience and in this
workshop
we know this pretty well but let's uh
remind us of the general paragraph the
idea is that we have a procedure
to determine the satisfiability of a
formula
this procedure searches for a model by
building candidate models
a model is typically represented by a
series of assignments
and assignments are propagated through
formulas
in order to get what are the logical
consequences of these assignments and
this propagation
usually is something fast um
when a conflict arises between the
candidate model and the formula
it is explained by inferences in such a
way that the
dilemma can be learned in order to avoid
repeating the same search and the same
conflict
the conflict is solved by fixing the
model to satisfy the long dilemma
and the key thing is that while
propagation are
relatively inexpensive inferences the
non-trivial inferences that are more
expensive are confined
to explain the conflicts to respond
to the conflicts and fix the model
accordingly
now this paradigm was brought forth
by cbcl for sat and then it was extended
first to several fragments of arithmetic
with the conflict-driven satisfiability
procedures for sets of literals
in values fragments of arithmetic then
the model constructing satisfiability in
paradigm by the young
showing how to combine in a in a
conflict-driven manner propositional
logic in one
theory and the citizen framework
conflict-driven satisfiability
shows how to do it for not only one
theory but for
a genetic combination of theories and
also for satisfiability module
assignments which means uh
histogram assignments may also be part
of the input
now what about first order logic here is
where
sdgs comes into the picture
and then the next question is can we get
decision procedures
from sdgs and the answer will be
mixed so sdgs will decide epr
in other fragments but it will not
decide some other fragments
but what is interesting is that the
decision procedures that we get from
sdgs
are conflict-driven and model
constructing which is rare
for a decision procedure synthetic stock
logic because for example
if you can't see the resolution-based
decision procedures
when they terminate and discover that
the set of clauses is satisfiable
they typically yield a saturated set of
clauses
which however does not represent a model
because resolution
is not a search procedure that proceeds
by searching for models and solving
conflicts
now let's see the basics about sdgis we
have an input set of clauses
the method is semantically guided which
means it adopts
a fixed brain interpretation eye to
guide the search
in general this interpretation is not
restricted
any brand interpretation will do but for
this talk we are going to consider
only sign based semantic guidance that
is
either the all negative interpretation
which satisfies all the negative
literals
are the all-positive interpretation
which satisfies
all the positive literals now
if the interpretation used for guidance
does not satisfy the site we need to
search for a model
sdgs works with a trail which is a
sequence of clauses with
selected literals this trail represents
an interpretation
which in essence is a modification of
the initial
interpretation i by satisfying the
selected literals
and then the method either get a trail
such that
the induced interpretation is a model of
the set of clauses
or else it discovers a contradiction
which tells
that the set of clauses isn't
satisfiable
now let's see the method through
examples rather than going through the
theories
suppose we have a set of clauses with pa
not px or qfy not px
or not qc very simple so that it fits on
one slide
and assume that the guiding
interpretation is all negative
clearly the guiding interpretation does
not satisfy the set because pa
is positive so what this ugs does
it performs an sdgs extension step
which puts pa on the trail and pa
is selected you see it is in bracket and
it is red
because it's the only literal in the
clause and therefore we have no choice
but to choose this literal
however sdgs has a preference for
selecting um
the positive literals when the guiding
interpretation is all negative and the
negative literals
when the guiding interpretation is all
positive
now with gamma one we have an
interpretation which satisfies all the
negative literals except pa
clearly such an interpretation is not a
model for not px
or qfy because it is sufficient to
instantiate x with
a to get the instances that are not
satisfied in this interpretation
so we add this instance not pa
or qfy to the trail with another sdgs
extension step which is generated
by unifying not px with the selected pa
so that
x gets a the positive literal is
selected
and the negative literal not pa is
mapped backward to the positive pa
selected to remember so to speak that
this literal that was true
in the initial interpretation is now
false because we are modifying the
interpretation in an attempt
to satisfy the set
now with gamma 2 the induced
interpretation
that does not satisfy the third clause
the
negative one because it does not satisfy
all the instances with x is instantiated
with a
and z with fy since now we have
these two red literals p a and q f y
being true
so in other sdgs extension with the
appropriate mgu
put this instance on the trail and again
now we need to choose a negative literal
because they are both negative
and this djs chooses the one that is
assigned
right most that is not qfy because it is
assigned to qfy
in the sense that the selection of qfy
makes not qfy false
now this clause is a conflict clause
because all its instances are false
in the current interpretation i gamma 3.
so we need to solve the conflict the way
sdgs
solves the conflict in this case when
the the conflict clause is
such that all its literals would have
been true in the original interpretation
in this case because they are both
negative is to move the conflict close
to the left and precisely move it
left of the clause who is the selected
literal qfy
makes not qfy false so you see this move
now the interpretation induced by gamma
4
clearly satisfies not qfy
because it's like this literal was
flipped
however now it is not p a q f y which is
in conflict because
both its literals are falsified
but this clause is not all negative it
has a positive literal
and therefore sdgs resolution intervenes
to resolve the third clause with the
second on the selected literal
literals and the resolvent which is not
pa
actually replaces the second premise
because resolution in sdgs is a very
restricted form of resolution
which applies only between clauses on
the trail
applies matching and not unification
and uses the resolvent to replace the
second parent the one which is not
iotro in this case the one which is not
negative
now not pa is in conflict because pa is
true
so it moves to the left of the clause
which makes it false
it resolves and we get the contradiction
by sdgs resolution
so how does this realize conflict-driven
reasoning in fact logic
literally clause l1 through lka
disjunction of literals where we select
literal lj the analog
of a decision in cdcl is an sdgs
extension which puts an instance of a
clause
on the trail and selects a literal
selecting the literal
means adding to the interpretation to
the candidate model
all the ground instances of the selected
literal
that are needed to satisfy this clause
note that not all of them may be needed
because some ground instances of
disclosed
c may be already satisfied by previews
selection already made on the tray but
when we add
an instance of the clause and we select
the literal we add
all the remaining instances
how does propagation work clearly we are
going to have a conflict close
when the current interpretation i gamma
induced by the current railgun
makes true all the complements of the
clause
so we have a clause l1 through lk and
all the complementary literals are true
so this one is in conflict
and we have an implied literal when all
the literals but
one lj are
false in the current interpretation so
to be precise it is not enough that they
are false what we need is that
their complements are true and then
this literal lj is implied because
making true all the ground distances of
lj
is the only way to satisfy this clause
and therefore it gets selected and it is
an implied literal and then as we saw in
the example conflict solving
involves conflict explanation by sdgs
resolution
and learning by svgs move so we don't
have a proper back jumping but
a rearrangement of the trail with with
the clothes migrating to the left
because the way we read the
interpretation from the trail
is from left to right and therefore
closes at smaller positions of priority
now let's see an example where sdgs find
the model
suppose we have these four clauses
and suppose again that the guiding
interpretation is all negative
clearly the first unit clause p x
x a is not satisfied so we put it on the
trail and we select
p x x a to make two all the ground
distances of literal p
where the first two arguments are equal
and the third
argument is a at this point
not only instances of the second clause
the one that starts
with p x y w
are satisfied because we lost
precisely all those instances
of the four that that were made true by
the third the negative literal because i
is all negative but now
they are no longer true because we made
p x x a
true so we do an f to gs extension
unifying this negative literal not p x
z w with p x x a
remember that every clause has its own
variables so the two x's are different
and we get an instance that we put on
the trail
we can select either one of the two
positive literals
suppose we selected the second one now
this means that we have a model
where all the negative literals are true
except
those of the form p x x a and those of
the form
p y x a but now these two literals have
an intersection because clearly all
instances of
p x x a are also instances of p
y pyxa so what is 2gs does when there is
an intersection it applies a rule called
splitting
to split the second clause and
distinguish
and do a partition where the first
clause
has as a selected literal a literal
whose ground instances are those in the
non-empty intersection with the first
whereas the second clause has a selected
literal the cup
choose the other instances so here x the
first two arguments are equal
and here the first and the second
argument are different because we have
the constraint
y different from x so splitting is the
rule which introduces constraints
in the system but now
this second clause is satisfied
because in the interpretation induced by
this trail
pxxa is true and therefore all ground
distances of this close are true and
therefore we can remove it
and we are left with these two clauses
which basically means that the final
interpretation satisfies
all negative literals except the literal
where the third argument of p is a
because this clause captures those where
the first and the second argument are
equal
and this clause captures those where the
first and the second argument are
different now this interpretation is a
model for
s because it obviously satisfies
the first clause and for the other
clauses
if the third argument if we consider an
instance a ground instance where the
third where
the third there is a literal where the
third argument of p
is a it is true with a positive one
either this one or this one or this one
otherwise
with a negative one now
um insta elimination on this set
expected
because sdgs terminated found the model
but we could ask
was it expected that that it terminates
is this something perhaps
spatial or trivial yes and no
why well hyper resolution
which is the semantic resolution with
the sign based
semantic guidance does not halt on this
set
so it is not so obvious that a method
with the sign based semantic guidance
would hold on this step now what is the
semantic resolution semantic resolution
is resolution restricted
to generate only solvents that are false
in a given guiding interpretation i
what is hyper resolution it is a
semantic resolution
with sign based semantic guidance so for
example in positive hyper resolution
we generate only positive clauses
because we assume as a semantic guidance
the all negative interpretation
and therefore in order to generate only
the solvents that are false
we generate only positive resolvence we
take a non-positive
clause c called the nucleus and we
resolve it simultaneously with as many
positive
clauses as needed to satellites or
electrons
to resolve the wave with the
simultaneous mgu all the negative
literals in the nucleus and get a
positive resolvent which is false
in the guiding interpretation now let's
see what ipr resolution does doesn't
dissect
hyper resolution generates infinitely
many clauses
so determination of its ugs is not
an easy thing for a semantic based
technique positive i play solution
generates infinitely many clauses from
the first two clauses because it takes
the second one the mixed one has no
clues
the first one p x x a as satellite
they resolve and generate the positive
clause which then can be used in
satellite again and so on forever
a negative hyperresolution generates
infinitely many clauses
from the third and the fourth clause now
this is actually a well-known
example which defeats hyper resolution
but on the other hand determination on
this set
is not so surprising because this set is
in the bernese
finkel class which is also known as
effectively propositional logic
it comprises all the sentence of the
form exists star of the role star fee
when fee has neither quantifiers nor
functions
when we translate it into clausal form
we apply is colonization so that all the
existentially quantified variables are
replaced by constants
there are no function symbols the hybrid
base is finite
and so we get decidability and indeed
there are multiple decision procedures
for this fragment including dplsx by
iruzhika and others
no redundant clause learning by allahi
and weidenbeck
a small model clause learning by fiori
and
now does this dgs decide epr yes
we should we shall show these shortly
does this ugs decide
other fragments some but not all
does this ugis allow us to allow us to
discover new decidable fragments
yes so let's see how
well first let's remember how sdgs makes
progress
in sdgs we call this joint prefix of the
trail
the longest prefix with no intersection
of selected literals
now suppose that the problem is not
solved
which means we didn't get the empty
clause so we didn't find a
satisfiability
and we didn't find the model yet so
there are two situations
either the trail is different for me to
disjoint prefix okay as it is equal
if it is different it means that either
there is
some intersection between selected
literals that will be removed by sdgs
splitting or else there is a conflict to
be solved
if they are equal but the set of clauses
is not satisfied
it means that for some clause in the set
some ground instance is not satisfied
and then
extension applies to extend the train
and therefore the current
interpretation why am i saying all these
because from this knowledge of how sdgs
makes progress
behind this there is a lifting theorem
that tells that sdgs extension
applies under these circumstances
in the radar theorem that tells that the
other rules apply otherwise
we glean that no termination may come
only from infinitely many extensions
because removing intersections
in solving conflicts and finite
activities that require
only finitely many steps
then in order to get the decision
procedure we also
need fairness of a derivation which
means the progress is made whenever
possible
if an extension adds a conflict clause
the conflict-solving inferences
follow immediately before any other
extension
deletion is applied eagerly it does not
happen that the strategy neglect
inferences and short-term prefixes of
the trade to work on longer one
and finally if we have a fair search
plan all derivations are failed and we
can define
the limit of a failed elevation which of
course may be infinite because the
problem is only semi-decidable in
general
now there are three fundamental theorems
about sdgs
one says that
um a descending chain of length bounded
trails is finite a fake degradation is a
descending chain
so we have in order trails to to show
these two results
then sdgis is refutationally complete
and it is model complete in the limit
so this is important because if we get a
decision procedure from sdgs
it will also provide a model
now refutational completeness ensures
extermination on unsatisfiable inputs
in order to get a decision procedure we
need determination of satisfiable inputs
so there are two ways to achieve this
i then show that the length of of the
trail during the derivation is bounded
because then we can apply this theorem
that says
a fake deliveration is a descending
chain and the descending chain
of length bounded trails is finite this
means basically that in order to go on
forever
the method needs to grow the length of
the trail
if the length of the trail is bounded it
cannot go on forever so in
sensitive is well behaved
sorry or else the other way to short
elimination on satisfiable inputs is to
show that
only finitely many extensions can apply
so let's start with the first technique
to prove decidability
in order to prove decidability we need
to find a finite subset
of the herbal base that is the set of
all the
ground instances of atoms in the
signature
such that all ground instances of all
clauses ever appearing on the trail
are made of atoms from the bases
basically the method has a finite
playground if there is a finite base
it will not generate atoms
outside of the bases now we
we can show that if a fake derivation
is in a finite basis at all stages
the length of the trail is upper bounded
by the cardinality of the finite basis
and therefore by the previous
fundamental theorems
a phase usgs derivation in a finite
basis is guaranteed to hold
now how to show that we have a decision
procedure for a fragment we need to show
that for all sets of clauses in the
fragment we have a finite basis which in
general
may depend on the set of clauses if we
manage to do this any failed strategy
will be a model constructing decision
procedure
for the fragment
also we can get the small model property
for any fragment that we show decidable
in this manner
why because remember that sdgs is model
constructing so if it terminates
the interpretation induced by the final
trail
is a model however this model is a
hegebron interpretation so it has
as domain as the universe which in
general is infinite
so that alone does not give us a finite
model
however if the derivation
is in a finite basis
we can take the set of terms
that appear as subterms in the atoms of
the bases
and we get a finite set of terms
which gives us a domain a finite domain
for a model
and we don't need anything bigger
because
we can build this model by determining
the truth of atoms
from the trail
now svgs decides epr actually it decides
it decides the generalization of epr to
the stratified fragment
this is um a fragment that was proposed
by abadi gabinovich
in 2010 one assumes they will founded
ordering on sorts
so that if we have a function from a
bunch of sorts these are the sorts of
the arguments
s 1 s n to an image of sort
s then the image of the sort is
strictly smaller than all the sorts
of the arguments if we draw
a sort dependency graph with an arc
from a sort appearing among the
arguments
to the sort of the image we get
a dependency graph which is a sick
cyclic
which means there are no infinite series
of terms such as
a f a f 2 of a and so on because we
don't have a cycle
of length 1 f on itself and we don't
have a cycle of length two so we cannot
build
a f a g f a f g f a and so on
in this case the finite basis is the
hybrid base itself
and epr is just a special case of the
stratified fragment with only one sort
because being having a well-founded
organized
with this property if there is only one
sort that can be satisfied only by
having
no function symbols
now can we get anything else beyond the
stratified fragment because
we are very happy that we can decide epr
because epr is practically relevant and
also the stratified fragment is
practically relevant
it was introduced to capture
several proof obligations in the alloy
system so stratified fragment is used in
verification
but on the other hand from a technical
point of view it is not too challenging
because the
brand base is finite so can we get
anything else
so because sdgs is semantically guided
by sign based interpretation
we consider a property which is useful
when the semantic guidance
is sign based namely ground preserving
clauses
a clause is positively ground preserving
if all the variables that appear in the
clause appear in negative literals
negatively ground preserving is dual
why is this property interesting because
if a set
is positively ground for something it
means that the positive clauses are
ground
because the seasonal variables must
appear in negative literals the only way
for a clause to be positive is to be
ground
in positive i play a solution since the
positive ip resolution only generates
positive clauses
will generate only positive ground
clauses will generate only positive
ground clauses
and we show that sdgs does the same
so with i minuses guidance given a
positively ground preserving set
it generates only positive
ground clauses now let's see an example
for a restrained clauses which is the
class
we are going to show decidable suppose
that we have this set of clauses
with the p109 i'm just reading
success or m times of zero as n
and then not p s s x y or p
x s y and finally a negative literal
now um what we see by the way
is that in this second clause the
atom p s s x y is larger
than the atom p x s y
for example it is larger in any
lexicographic path ordering because
s x x is larger than x
but also in any cluster index ordering
where s is positive weight because here
we have two r currencies of s and here
only one
now what happens is that sdgs
will generate a ground elevation because
the site is ground preserving
it will generate only ground literals
the new literals are ground and
furthermore
they are getting smaller and smaller
because for example if we put
on the trail p109 in order to satisfy
the first clause
then the following sdgs extensions will
generate the instances of the second
clause
needed to satisfy it so for example
unifying
p109 with this lit with the negative
literal of the second clause
we get p8 10 and then
we get p6 11 and so on until
we find p014 and the process terminating
the last interpretation is the model of
these clauses
so we can generalize this concept by
introducing a quasi ordering that we
call restraining quasi-ordering that is
a
nice properties it is a stable under
substitution
district ordering is well founded and
the
um and the equivalence relation has
finite equivalence classes
and then we say that a set of clauses is
positively restrained
if it is positively ground preserving
and for all non-ground positive literals
there is a negative literal that is
larger
why do we consider requisite ordering
and not just strict
ordering because by using a quasi
ordering we can also conquer clauses of
this form
difference y of not d for yx
which embodies the commutativity
property
because we can order it by making one
liter
larger than the other in a recognitive
path organic that is compatible with
associativity and commutativity
now we can show that residues decides
a restrained fragment because given
such a set of clauses we can take the
set of ground atoms that appear
in the set of clauses we can take as
finite bases the set of ground
atoms upper bounded in the ordering by
those that appear in the input
so we take all the l in the herbin base
such that there is a name
among the ground atoms appearing in the
input such that
m is greater equal than l and then we
prove
that any failed degradation by sdgs with
a suitable interpretation that is if
if the set is positively ground
preserving it will be i minus
is in this basis therefore it holds
and it is a decision procedure and
furthermore if the set is satisfiable
it will have a model of this size so the
cardinality of the set of
terms of the set of ground terms
extracted from the finite bases plus one
so for example the previous set as a
cardinality
has a model of cardinality 21
because if you go back you see that we
have
10 and 19 so we cannot have in a kbo
any term with greater than 19 times
s so we get 20 from 0 to 19 plus 1.
we can also show by using the finite
basis technique
that s2gis decides the positive variable
dominated fragment
which is an already known fragment also
built on ground
around positively ground preserving
closes
the restrained fragment is pretty well
behaved
because we can show that it is decided
also by ip resolution
but then the question is okay we have
this restrained
property but how can we determine that
the set of clauses is restrained
this the the problem can be approached
by reducing it to termination of the
guide system now in general this is an
undecidable problem of course
but there exists tools such as the tt
t2 or a proof which allows to
determine whether mainly guide systems
of interest
after eliminating or not so we
if we have a gripe system in fact a page
of great systems
r and e associated to s
such that for all non-ground uh positive
literal
there is a great rule so that
a negative literal is larger in the
great relation
so there is a rule rewriting m to l
with the second guide system reserved to
handle permutative rules
like in the commutativity case for
differ
we have a lamb that shows that if this
guide system is terminating
then s is positively restrained
or else we need a termination of
modulo the rules in
e
so we can run experiments we
take problems from the library ptp
version 7.2.0 we take
all the problems in the first order
formula category without equality
we reduce them to clausal form and we
get
a 5001 benchmarks then
we wrote a script to generate the guide
systems from the set of clauses
we and we can apply the termination tool
to determine whether the guide system
terminates now on
1539 inputs
either tool unfortunately timed out
but out of the remaining problems the
termination tool discovered
349 that are restrained
43 of which do not belong to any other
previously known decidable class
saga wrote a prototype fear improver
based on sdgs which is named koala
it is built on code from constantin
carlovin's approval
it uses a discrimination tree for fast
unification when performing extension
it implements a fake search plan it
recognizes the stratified problems by
checking for a simplicity
of the sorts and it picks i minus
or i plus here there's a typo that has
to be an a plus
based on whether the input is positively
or negatively ground preserving which is
used
as an approximation of positively or
negatively restraining
in the experiments out of 349 restrained
problems that we discovered
koala determined that 50 are satisfiable
and to uh 283 and satisfiable
we also applied the two pvd problems the
greg 351 pvd problems
in the fourth category of tptp
so koala found 232 unsatisfiable
and 76 satisfiable and furthermore in
that class there are 1200
satisfied problems starting stratified
problems
out of which koala found 277 satisfiable
and 643 unsatisfiable
now on the negative side we found
counter examples
showing the rest of gs does not decide
other fragments such as
monadic fo2 and garden which on the
other hand
can be decided by resolution based
decision procedure based on argument
resolution but significantly
not hyper resolution because these sets
defeat
sign based semantic guidance these are
the fragments of which
moshe was saying that they didn't find
many applications
with respect to epr and stratified but
nonetheless from the theoretical point
of view they are
interesting so we checked whether svgs
may decide then but we found counter
examples for each of these
now i'm going to wrap it up so um
current work we are studying a precise
relationship between
sdgs and hyper resolution we already
proved
that if clauses are ground preserving
sdgs is guaranteed to hold
whenever hyper resolution does this
implies that the qgs decides also the
bdi fragment which is another
decidable fragment infrastructure logic
then we discovered
new decidable fragments by using sdgs
the salt restrained fragment which is a
generalization of both
restrained and stratified fragment
because it is restrained only on cyclic
sorts
thoughts that are a cyclic are
not a problem because of stratification
similarly the societal find pvd fragment
which imposes the ppd condition positive
variable dominated
only on literals in the cyclic source
and then the controlled fragment which
is not ground preserving
which is shown decidable however only
the horn case
by using the second approach to
decidability that i outlined earlier
namely showing that there are only
finitely mainly
sdgs extensions then we are also
studying modularity of termination
and complexity in terms of derivation
length
now for future work we are interested in
developing the equal approval with more
work on strategies
and the basic algorithm inside the
prototype
and of course we are interested in
extension to equality which may come
either by embedding superposition in
sdgs
hopefully in a conflict-driven way as
much as possible although equality does
not lend itself very well
to um conflict-driven reasoning in
general so
uh there will have to be some compromise
and another exciting possibility is to
do
um go in the other direction and embed
sdgs in series up
which is our approach for
conflict-driven satisfiability in smt in
union of theories
and so we could have sdgs as the module
is easier to handle fixed token logic of
decidable fragments such as
epr also we want to investigate of
course
any initial interpretations not based on
sign
these are all the references so the work
of decision procedures appear that each
car
in 2020 and we are working on the
journal version
whereas sdgs is presented in two papers
on the journal of automated reasoning
and with this i would like to thank you
very much for your kind attention
thank you so thank you let me clap
in everyone's name for your nice talk
maria paula
it was very fascinating to see uh new
uh directions in uh first order logic
so uh let's open the floor for questions
and uh i will first read the
moshe's question but you can see but i
think you already answered
because he asked whether you could use
your solver
for uh fo2 and uh you already said that
uh
you cannot do you want to because
i can't do you want to add maybe
explanation yes
sure sure let me um actually go back
to um the full screen and go back to
that
slide so here are the negative results
so f42 is
one of the cases where sdgs fails to
provide
a decision procedure and basically we
just
took a pretty famous example from the
paper by
by joiner the paper in jacm 1976
there is a set of clauses which can be
obtained
by transforming into clausal form a
formula
which belongs simultaneously to
ackermann monadic and
fo2 and we can show that this ugs does
not
terminate on that set of clauses
regardless
of whether the interpretation is i plus
or i mine also
of course one could say what does ugs
could do if we find a different initial
interpretation
and that is actually
[Applause]
still open but at least we can say
that it cannot terminate regardless of
initial interpretation because
remember that when we say that sdgs is
executionally complete
it is regardless of initial
interpretation
and also model completeness in the limit
is obtained
regardless of initial interpretation
the decidability results on the other
hand
have been obtained for sine base the
semantic guidance that is assuming
either a plus which makes true of the
positive literals
or i minus which makes through all the
negative literals
and also the decidability results have
been obtained
for these sign-based guiding
interpretation
with those we know that it does not
terminate because we have the counter
example
with some other brand interpretation
um we don't know actually
before i ask my questions i will give a
chance others to ask questions because i
think
i have a little question that might
require more discussion so
uh is there anyone else who would like
to questions
uh let's see either please raise your
hand i mute yourself
or just start to talk let's see
okay so uh maybe then let me start while
the others are deciding
um everything was very clear i guess so
my question is
the following i would like to how
you said something that i was not quite
uh so you said that this is somehow
different than standard first order
resolution of theory improvers because
resolution
as per say is not does not construct the
model
but i somehow always looked at the
resolution like
really as a model constructing uh review
or
to the first order logic because if you
think about
you said okay it's refutationally
complete i agree the resolution is also
reputationally complete and if you look
at the work by
gunsinger and bachmaire where they
actually introduce
ordering on the clauses and then they
you know like
construct model it is really actually
resolution is reputationally complete
because they are actually uh describing
how to construct the model
and then when you can't construct model
you actually have the proof
of unsatisfiability and the other thing
that uh
nana was trying all the time to
put parallel between the work that you
presented
and they exist and again going back like
i i have to go back to my uh
uh background right to go to gansing
kirbak my mother construction
service then looking like when you were
describing uh
deletion that you if you don't have too
many too much deletions
that uh looking back would be probably
if
you have deleting a clause which is not
subsumed by the other clauses or
in their terminology if you're deleting
the clause
that is greater than this than the
clause that you already have in the
model
so my question is like uh i don't know
how i think
uh how familiar you are or uh can you
did you already
look into parallel between your work
and uh this all the old results of a gun
singer bachmann when they actually
describe how to well they uh that
actually
[Music]
uh provide foundations uh of a
resolution
and they show easily that its reputation
we complete and how to construct the
model
[Laughter]
okay now if you consider
a solution you see that not only
in the work by bachmann gunzinger but
throughout the history of resolution the
refutational completeness of resolution
has always been shown by showing that
the set of clauses isn't satisfiable
because a model construction
is bounded to fail because if you
consider the very first
proof of gravitational completeness of
resolution the one by robinson
it was done considering semantic trees
so you have a semantic tree which is a
survey
of all possible brand interpretations
and one
shows that the resolution collapses it
so that at the end
if the set of clauses isn't satisfiable
um
it is bounded to get the empty clause
which is like having a semantic tree
with only the root
labeled by the empty clause now when
organized resolution and organization
modulation were introduced
young and mikhail guzinovic
showed again the refutational
completeness
of ordered resolution without the
paramodulation and simplification and
subsumption
by using trans-finite semantic trees
where the transfinite nature of the
trees was coming precisely from the
addition of equality
because if you have for instance the
recursive path ordering
you can have infinitely many ground
terms
before you get to a next bunch of
infinitely many gram terms so the
semantic trees
had to become transfiner in order to
accommodate equality
then what batman and gunzinger did
with the old red resolution
superposition or
modulation and so on was to propose
another model constructing technique
which is the one you mentioned
which is the the right model
construction so in the proof
of refutational completeness one shows
exactly that if the certificated set by
this inference system
does not contain the empty clause then
it is satisfiable
and this is done by this model
construction argument
so why did i say that resolution is not
mobile constructing even if in the
history of your improving
all the proofs of refutational
completeness of all the values variants
of resolution
involve considering a survey of models
and showing that if the set of clauses
isn't satisfiable this construction must
fail
and the contradiction must arise because
resolution
does not build the model explicitly
so the model construction is
in the proof of revolutional
completeness but when resolution
works it does not build the model it
takes a set of clauses
and it generates resolvence and it
adds them to the set of clauses so it
expands the set
and then it applies the subsumption
simplification all the contraction rules
to reduce the set but the model
is not explicitly represented
okay because what you have is a set of
clauses not the representation of a
model
on the other hand in sdgis we have a
trail of clauses
from which at every stage we can read
a hellbrand interpretation which is
the initial brand interpretation
modified
in all the selected literals so you can
actually
watch during the run of the prove
the model evolving whereas in resolution
it remains simplistic
so you cannot work on it explicitly
by a mechanism like conflict solving
which solves the conflict between the
candidate model
and the clause because you don't see the
candidate model
the model construction part is in the
proof of gravitational completeness but
is not in the operation of the method
whereas in sdgs the train
is really the representation of a fixed
order mode
in fact a partial model and you get
a complete model by completing it how
by consulting the initial interpretation
that's why we have an initial
interpretation
because we otherwise i mean
the problem in fact the logic is always
how to represent
finitely in my in first order model
right so we have a partial model
which is on the trail and then we
complete it
by looking at the default interpretation
does this help penny
i don't know i still somehow uh
i maybe but because um
so whenever i still when i think about
resolution
i mean i we do construct models but
maybe it's
implementations do not produce models
but looking at some
older version i mean uh if you when or
even in this past
when you say like like as a modern
proverb even you will say complete
completion
found and then you will see the set of
all saturated clauses and from this
set of saturated clauses you can
actually project back to the model so
maybe
yeah it's uh yes but you okay but
it's a saturated satisfiable set does
not give you per se
in model you need to extract it and it
is not always possible
as far as i know i don't think i mean
we know that the set is satisfiable but
this does not mean that it represents a
model
i mean this is true i think i have to
think a little bit about this
more yeah because uh yeah
we should we should talk more about that
it's a really fascinating person
extract the model from a celebrated site
but i don't think they are universal
i i think i believe that it's a way to
say they said
this is satisfiable that's universally
true
yes we achieve completion if we get the
final certificate that set without the
empty clause it is satisfiable
that's the theorem yeah but it doesn't
represent a model per se
but whereas here the interpretation
is uh um the interpretation is spelled
out in a sense it is really
the structure a representation of the
model is the structure where the
procedure operates
so i don't think it is the difference of
implementation i think it's a difference
of operation
now of course you can tell me but
there's still an analogy and then i'll
say
yes because it's the same logic i mean
we it is still for logic so
it's completeness and the refutational
completeness of the animator consider
also tableau
all kinds of methods for extracted logic
there is
some similarity in the end because the
logic is the same
but if you look at the operation of the
method
resolution works by saturation that is
by adding clauses
and deleting those that are redundant
where whereas sdgs works by trying to
build the model so it acts
lazily only to satisfy one of the
clauses that in the input that are not
yet satisfied
and it does not generate resolvence it
generates instances
the generation of resolvence is
restricted only
to conflict solving so only when there
is a conflict between the candidate
model
and the input clauses we perform a
resolution
not in general we don't saturate
by doing all the possible resolutions
modular redundancy
as in or the resolution a superposition
it's a such a shame that this is not in
person because now we could
just go out
but this is um actually let's ask
is there maybe uh someone from the
audience says i gave you a chance guys
before but you
that since you didn't ask it kind of
took all maria palace time so is there
any remaining question
if not then indeed we could uh go to for
a
coffee because i think now it's the
coffee time
at simon's but as everything it's a
virtual coffee so
thank you for staying and uh i'll
talk will see us again next week okay
thank you very much thank you bye
everyone